اعطوني اياه للحفاظ على سلامتي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ناس كتير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وببدايه الثوره كان في بين
عشره اليوم
بس مع مرور الوقت صار هالعدد يزيد
يعني
وصلنا نصور اكثر من 40 جسر اليوم كنا نشوف
جثث للشيوخ
شباب
حتى اطفال
ما كان عليهم اسمهم
كل الجثث كان في عليها لزقه او ورقه
فيها رقمين
هو الرقم هو للمعتقل
والتاني رقم الفرن
[موسيقى]
كل يوم المسا
بس يرجع المصور من مهمه التصوير
في حاجه مسؤول عن نقل الصور من الكاميرا
للكمبيوتر الخاص بالقسم كان يفرز صور
الضحايا لمجلدات
كل جثه حسب الفرع من اجت منه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كنت لابس قميص حبه
علي
مينا بالسليب
الغنم
غرفه 12 متر بسبع امتار
هو اول ما فتتوا ريحه العرق خيو دخت وقعت
بالارض بس انه في ناس كتير قتلهم قدامي
كانوا معي
[موسيقى]
عبد الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تعرفت بصور قيصر على صوره زوجي وصوره اخي
انا تعرفت بصور قيصر
تعرفت على صوره ابني ايهم وهو شهيد
فالصور اللي شفتها في اطفاء للحياه مش بس
قتل